So why is configuration hard to get
right? First, it's difficult to define what we
mean by correct behaviour in the first
place. Second, the interactions between multiple routing protocols
can lead to unpredictability. Furthermore, each autonomous
system on the internet is independently configured. And
the interaction between the policies of these autonomous
systems can lead to unintended, or unwanted behaviour.
The third reason that configuration is
hard, is that operators simply make mistakes.
Configuration is difficult, and network policies
are very complex. Furthermore, Network configuration has
historically been distributed across hundreds, or
more, network devices. Across the network where
each device is configured with vendor-specific
low-level configuration. We'll see in the first
part of this course how Software Defined Networking or SDN changes this,
by centralizing the network's configuration in
a logically centralized controller. At a
very high level, Software Defined Networking
provides exactly the primitives that operators
need to run the network better.
In particular, SDN provides operators three things.
The first, is network-wide views of both topology and traffic. The second,
is the ability to satisfy network level objectives such as those that we talked
about before including load balance, security,
and other high level goals. The third
thing, that software defined networking provides
that network operators need, is direct control.
In particular, rather than requiring network operators to configure each
device individually with indirect configuration, SDN
allows an operator to write a control program that directly
affects the data plane. So rather than having to
configure each device individually and guess or infer what might
happen, software-defined networking allows a network operator to express network
level objectives and direct control from A logically centralized controller. So
to make network operations easier, routers should forward packets
since router hardware is specialized to forward traffic at very high rates.
They should collect measurements such as traffic
statistics and topology information. But on the
other hand, there's no reason that a
router should have to compute routes. Although,
conventionally, routing has operated as a distributed
computation of forwarding tables, the computation doesn't
inherently need to run on the routers.
Rather, the computation could be logically centralized,
and controlled, from a centralized control program.
This logical centralization is the fundamental tenant
of SDN. So a simple way of summing up Software Defined Networking is simply
to remove routing from the routers, and
perform that routing computation at a logically
centralized controller. Now of course, SDN has
evolved to incorporate, a much broader range
of controls than simply routing decisions, and we'll talk about the range
of control that SDN controllers enable
in today's networks, throughout this lesson.